and are you typically a pretty open book
with your career what are some of the
things you regret about your career
mistakes things you which you have done
differently perhaps well now that I've
wised up to the benefits of economic
freedom
I regret much of my first 20 years of
bashing business of calling for more
regulation because of this problem and
that's the intuitive reaction you send
the TV out to 15 repair shops some
people cheat you politicians call me up
and say oh great piece we're gonna do a
establish Department of Consumer Affairs
and licensed TV repair shops and car
repair shops and if you're if you
haven't read Reason magazine it sounds
good because you like licensing licensed
dogs and drivers it just sounds like the
right thing to do and I encourage that
sort of thing for many years so I regret
much of that I just scare stories danger
in the grass lawn chemicals that were
over-the-top and I was worried about
exploding coffee pots through my whole
childhood because of you I did a story
on somebody who died because their house
caught fire because their coffee pot
blew up and you know these things do
happen but it's a big country a lot of
nasty stuff happening to people you got
50 people who die every year from
plastic bags so well they're banning
those to say oh well what about the
flipside they're the things that you
look back and you're truly proud of what
you've done what are your greatest
accomplishments my first was this show
called are we scaring ourselves to death
but finally when I said gee were scaring
people about everything we ought to put
this in perspective and I read searching
for safety by Aaron Ville doubts key
which really opened my brain and tried
then to put risks in perspective and it
was tough to get on the air to freelance
producers quit rather than work on that
show they said that's not objective
that's conservative dog want to say that
regulation itself might hurt people and
fortunately the ABCs credit producers
said we don't agree with you but this is
an argument that deserves to be heard I
put the show on I wanted to call it we
are scaring you to death and they
wouldn't let me but
the eventual show are we scaring you to
death with a counterpoint on Nightline
where they argued with me
got surprisingly good ratings and good
reaction from scientists who said
finally a breath of fresh air telling
the truth about some of these issues
that started me on a somewhat
independent career of having specials
every year and so I'm very proud of that
that was a scary point where I thought I
was finished and then more recently we
did one called
stupid in America which is another
example of the market in a way that the
show could have been called education
what works or something like that but my
boss said education is boring no one's
gonna watch that we'll call it's stupid
in America and I didn't want to imply
that the teachers are stupid because
many are not and many are heroic and how
hard they work but that the system of
sending kids into a government monopoly
when they never serve their customers
will was stupid and I worried that if
the show wouldn't be well-received
because education doesn't good TV it's
just people kids sitting at a desk but
the ratings we get minute by minute
ratings now they went straight up and
was the highest watched show that night
and as was the repeat and it argued
pretty forcefully that choice and
competition might make a big difference
and it woke me up to some of the things
we discovered in the research that this
argument that the the reason it's
failing is that we're not spending
enough money we're spending 11 foul per
student if you do the math that's more
than $200,000 per classroom think you
could do with that money higher for
excellent teachers and it just shows
that government monopolies waste money
and and that stirred the pot some I'm
happy with that sure I know one thing
that you're you're proud of it's docile
in the classroom what's what is that and
what do you accomplish I'm very
interested in that now we do these shows
and they cost ABC almost half a million
bucks and then they air and they're gone
and teachers sometimes wrote saying gee
I wish I taped that because I wanted to
show it in class or we did
tape it and I showed it in class and the
kids quiet kids have never spoken all
year suddenly they were up arguing we
had a great discussion can we get more
of these things to use in classrooms and
I had some shows like greed that we did
or is America number one which discusses
why is America prosperous and you asked
kids and they say well it's because we
have democracy and we have natural
resources and I point out what India has
democracy and natural resources India's
poor well India is overpopulated
well actually the population density of
India is the same as that of New Jersey
and New Jersey's doing ok and Hong Kong
has no natural resources and 20 times as
many people per square foot Hong Kong
got rich in 50 years it went from third
world to first world because his Milton
Friedman points out economic freedom and
that's of course the answer to why a
country's prosperous the British rulers
in Hong Kong enforced rule of law kept
people and property safe and then they
sat around the drank tea they left
people alone to me that's such a
valuable lesson for kids and I'm
delighted that it's now in half of
America's public high schools weirdly
more public school teachers are asking
for these and now I have a nonprofit
that raises money to buy them from ABC
and so at Stossel the classroom org any
teacher can get these DVDs positions
you've been taking for years and years
and years some of them against corporate
welfare against greedy peddlers of junk
science ripping people off in favor of
gay rights free speech in favor of
legalizing prostitution in favor of
legalizing drugs so there's a lot for
conservatives to to hate about you and
there should be a lot of for liberals to
love about you and yet it seems almost
always that you're widely adored by
conservatives and widely scorned by
liberals why is that I'm not sure but
you're absolutely right and somebody
came up to me in New York and said are
you John Stossel yes I hope he dies so
and he was a legal aid lawyer and there
is this real hatred among the left
because I'm a consumer reporter
defending business and they just so hate
business I don't know I be I'm
pro-choice I was against the war in Iraq
I think homosexuality is just fine I
want drugs legal and prostitution legal
yet conservatives invite me to their
conferences and give me standing
ovations sometimes not all of us but
they generally like what I have to say
and I even mention some of that and I it
shows how pathetic it is for
conservatives in the mainstream media
that that I a libertarian to the closest
thing that they have to invite to a
conference and then the Liberals being
so angry this hatred of business and I'm
not sure what that's about I used to
think it was about Envy that the college
professor is angry that his Slightly
Stoopid a roommate is making more money
than he is because he's in business and
he's a professor not making as much but
and the disparity of wealth is a little
uncomfortable or a lot uncomfortable but
then you think about the kings and
queens of Europe Tom soles point this
out people didn't hate them for all
their wealth and their wealth
proportionately was vastly greater than
now but they hated the bourgeoisie they
gave him that nasty name they hated the
very people who sold them the things
that they needed to make their lives
better so what's that about and my best
guess is that it's the intuitive
reaction again that the world is a
zero-sum game that if he makes profit
off you you must have lost something and
if you don't study economics that is how
people think I know I see why
politicians think that way because
that's how their world works one wins
somebody else has to lose but we have a
lot of work to do to explain that free
Commerce doesn't work that way that
everybody gains can you talk a little
bit about your collaboration with Reason
TV drew Carey how it came about
well reasons always meant a lot to me in
that when I was
austan the political wilderness and
politically naive and it didn't make
sense what the conservatives were saying
in the magazines I read that they did
and the Liberals who controlled the
media where I am what they said which
was all this government will fix it and
we just have to spend more made no sense
and discovering reason was just
wonderful I could see that wow there's
another way to think about these things
so I've always read the magazine
Virginia posture l was my teacher
originally and when you guys started
doing television I thought great let's
take the best of it and spy it or steal
it you you don't mind the competition
are you worried about us I like the
competition if I were more worried that
you would eclipse me I would still like
it because my goal is just to get these
ideas out
you